Welcome to bonus programming gem #1.
This part is completely optional in that there are no quizzes.
I'm going to lay out a programming problem and show you how I would approach it
and debug it and give you some hints.
If you already feel comfortable after seeing the problem, then you can skip it.
Otherwise, follow along with me.
At a high level, here's the problem description that we'll be tackling today.
Given a list 'l' of arbitrary elements--could be strings, could be numbers,
could be lists themselves--and a function 'f',
return the element of 'l' that maximizes that function.
So for example, if the function is square root and the list is 9, 16, 4,
we'd want to return 16 because it has the highest square root.
And we can assume that 'l' is not empty and that 'f' returns a number.
Let's show an example.
Let's say that the list is a list of strings--['Barbara', 'Kingsolver', 'wrote', 'the',
'Poisonwood', 'Bible'],
and the function we're trying to maximize is len--the string length function.
So among the 6 elements, 'Poinsonwood' has 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 letters.
'Kingsolver'--1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10--also 10 letters, returning either one of those
would be fine.
What I encourage you to do at this point is, try it on your own!
Go to the Python interpreter, make up some test cases, implement a function that does this,
and then we'll all go through it together.